let's imagine a sculptor building a
statue just chipping away with this
chisel Michelangelo had this elegant way
of describing it when he said every
block of stone has a statue inside of it
and it's the task of the sculptor to
discover it but what if he worked in the
opposite direction not from a solid
block of stone from a pile of dust
somehow gluing millions of these
particles together to form a statue I
know that's an absurd notion it's
probably impossible the only way you get
a statue from a pile of dust is if the
statue built itself if somehow we could
compel millions of these particles to
come together to form the statue Oh as
odd as that sounds that is like almost
exactly the problem I work on in my lab
I don't build with stone I build with
nano materials there are these just
impossibly small fascinating little
objects they're so small that if this
controller was a nanoparticle a human
hair would be the size of this entire
room and there at the heart of a field
we called nanotechnology which I'm sure
we've all heard about and we've all
heard how it is going to change
everything you know when I was a
graduate student it was one of the most
exciting times be working in
nanotechnology there were scientific
breakthroughs happening all of the time
the conferences were buzzing there was
tons of money pouring in from funding
agencies and the reason is when objects
get really small they're governed by a
different set of physics that govern
ordinary objects like the ones we
interact with we call this physics
quantum mechanics and what it tells you
is that you can precisely tune their
behavior just by making seemingly small
changes to them like adding or removing
a handful of atoms or twisting the
material it's like this ultimate toolkit
you really felt empowered you felt like
you could make anything and we were
doing it and by we I mean you know my
whole generation of graduate students we
were trying to make blazing fast
computers using nanomaterials we were
constructing quantum dots that could one
day go in your body and find and fight
disease there were even groups trying to
make an elevator to space
using carbon nanotubes you can look that
up that's true anyways we thought it
wouldn't affect all parts of Science and
Technology from computing to medicine
and I have to admit I drank all of the
kool-aid I mean every last drop but that
was like 15 years ago
and we took fantastic science was done
really important work we've learned a
lot we were never able to translate that
science into new technologies into
technologies that could actually impact
people and the reason is these
nanomaterials they're like a
double-edged sword the same thing that
makes them so interesting their small
size also makes them like impossible to
work with it's literally like trying to
build a statue out of a pile of dust and
we just don't have the tools that are
small enough to work with them but even
if we did it wouldn't really matter
because we couldn't one by one place
millions of particles together to build
a technology so because of that all of
the promise and all of the excitement
has remained just that promise and
excitement we don't have any disease
fighting nanobots
there's no elevators to space and the
thing that I'm most interested in no new
types of computing now that last one
that's a really important one we just
have come to expect the pace of good
computing advancements to go on
indefinitely we've built entire
economies on this idea and this pace
exists because of our ability to pack
more and more devices onto a computer
chip and as those devices get smaller
they get faster they consume less power
and they get cheaper and it's these this
convergence that caught that gives us
this incredible pace as an example if I
took the room sized computer that sent
three men to the moon and back and
somehow compressed it okay
compress like the world's greatest
computer of its day so it was the same
size as your smartphone your actual
smartphone that thing you spent 300
bucks on it just toss out every two
years would blow this thing away like
you would not be impressed it couldn't
do anything that your smartphone does it
would be slow you couldn't put any of
your stuff on it you could possibly get
through like the first two minutes of a
Walking Dead episode if you're lucky
the point is the progress it's not
gradual the progress is relentless it's
exponential it compounds on itself year
after year to the point where if you
compare a technology from one generation
to the next
they're like almost unrecognizable and
we owe it to ourselves to keep this
progress going we want to say the same
thing 10 20 30 years from now look what
we've done over the last 30 years yet we
know this progress may not last forever
in fact the party is kind of winding
down it's like like last call for
alcohol right if you look under the
covers by many metrics like speed and
performance the progress has already
slowed to a halt so if we want to keep
this party going we have to do what
we've always been able to do and that is
to innovate so our groups are groups
role in our groups mission is to
innovate by employing carbon nanotubes
because we think that they can provide a
path to continue this pace they are just
like they sound their tiny hollow tubes
of carbon atoms and their nano scale
size that small size gives rise to these
just outstanding electronic properties
and the science tells us if we could
employ them in computing we could see up
to a 10 times improvement in performance
it's like skipping through several
technology generations in just one step
so there we have it we have like this
really important problem and we have
what is basically the ideal solution the
science is like screaming at us like
this is what you should be doing to
solve your problem but you so it's like
all right you know let's get started
let's do this then you just run right
back into that double-edged sword this
ideal solution contains a material
that's second impossible to work with
I'd have to arrange billions of them
just to make one single computer chip
it's that same conundrum it's like this
undying problem so this point we said
let's just stop let's not go down that
same road let's just figure out like
what's missing right what are we not
dealing with what are we not doing that
needs to be done it's like in The
Godfather right when Fredo betrays his
brother Michael like we all know what
needs to be done I mean Fredo's got to
go but Michael you know he puts it off
and like fine I get it their mother's
still alive it would make her upset we
just said like what's the Fredo in our
problem
like what are we not dealing with what
are we not doing but needs to be done to
make this a success and the answer is
that the statue has to build itself we
have to find a way somehow to compel to
compel to convince billions of these
particles to assemble themselves into
the technology okay we can't do it for
them you know they have to do it for
themselves and it's the hard way and
this is not trivial but in this case
it's the only way now as it turns out
this is not that alien of a problem okay
we just don't build anything this way
right people don't build anything this
way but if you look around and there's
examples everywhere
mother nature builds everything this way
everything is built from the bottom up
all right you can go to the beach you'll
find these simple organisms that use
proteins just basically molecule says to
template what is essentially sand just
plucking it from the sea and building
these extraordinary architectures with
extreme diversity and nature's not crude
like us just hacking away I mean she's
elegant and smart building with what's
available molecule by molecule making
structures with a complexity and a
diversity that we can't even approach
and she's already at the Nano she's been
there for hundreds of millions of years
you know we're the ones that are late to
the party so we decided we're going to
use the same tool that nature uses and
that's chemistry chemistry is the
missing tool and chemistry works in this
case because these nanoscale objects are
about the same size as molecules so we
can use them to steer these objects
around much like a tool as exactly what
we've done in our lab we've developed
chemistry that goes into the pile of
dust into the pile of nano particles and
pulls out exactly the ones we need then
we can use chemistry to arrange
literally billions of these particles
into the pattern we need to build
circuits and because we can do that we
can build circuits that are many times
faster than what anyone's been able to
make using nanomaterials before
chemistry is a missing tool and every
day our tool gets sharper and gets more
precise and eventually we hope this is
within a handful of years we can deliver
on one of those original promises now
computing is just one example it's the
one that I'm
to sit in that my group is really vested
in but there are others in renewable
energy in medicine instructional
materials where the science is going to
tell you to move towards a nano that's
where the biggest benefit is but if
we're going to do that the scientists of
today and tomorrow are going to need new
tools tools just like the ones I
described and if the beauty of sign and
don't need chemistry it's a point they
won't need chemistry and the beauty of
science is that once you develop these
new tools they're out there I mean
they're out there forever and anyone
anywhere can pick them up and use them
use them and help to deliver on the
promise of nanotechnology so thank you
so much for your time